okay let's see who's joining us from the
four one three area code a really good
way to get on very quickly is to call
from the 401 three area code because
that's our home area code from Western
Massachusetts
who's there from four one three hi David
my name is Tom I'm calling from a Guam
all right go ahead Tom Agra wanna by the
way if I'm a Tom before you jump right
into that Agawam has the zip code Oh 100
one and unless I've been repeating this
incorrectly for like twenty years
it is the first zip code like because
zip codes are two sections it's the
first two numbers and then the last
three numbers so Agawam is oh one and
then oo one is that right Tom are you is
that something you're aware of that is
true it's split so I'm in a 100 3 or
something oh god if I don't that ain't
never done I think that I'm sorry yeah I
just have a question regarding the
congressional race in my district right
now yep
Ritchie Neal has been our congressman
for very long time he's sort of a more
conservative Democrat and there's a
progressive challenger to hear a a
module would dude if I'm pronouncing
that correctly and she's very
progressive supports universal health
care the whole deal on that but her
opponents have been sort of smearing her
because she is a Muslim and she
apparently was a chairperson on the
Council on american-islamic relations
right which has apparently ties to Hamas
and some other nefarious Muslim groups
are you at all familiar with the Council
on american-islamic relations yes is
something that I should be concerned
about how boy I mean listen I know
Ritchie Neal he's been a guest on this
program I've not been following that
race because I don't I don't live there
anymore and there's only so many
congressional races you can follow
I think Ritchie Neal is he's not Joe
Manchin right I mean yeah he's not the
most progressive guy but he's not he you
know we don't want to say that he's just
a sort of corporate Democratic shill I
don't know his opponent but I
would I would look very closely into
into care care I think is how they say
it's CAIR the Council on
american-islamic relations I would look
very closely I would have some concerns
about that although I would want to know
more about the candidates specific
history with the group like yes just
because there is this connection to
Hamas doesn't mean that this individual
is someone we we on principle shouldn't
vote for that's just something to look
into right all right yeah thank you all
right very good appreciate the call good
to hear from western mass you never know
you know what's what what we're gonna
hear from western mass